Every Monday, John, and Thax, and Ericka get together at John's apartment to watch Dark Shadows . You know, Dark Shadows , surely you've heard of it.
每个周一，约翰、萨克斯和艾丽卡都会聚在约翰的公寓里看《黑暗阴影》。你知道《黑暗阴影》吧，你肯定听说过它。
It was the most popular thing in the whole world, at one point.
它曾经是全世界最受欢迎的节目。
No.
不。
It was.
确实是。
John used to watch four or five hours of Dark Shadows every day, back in January when he was unemployed. Now he only watches four hours a week and only with his friends. And, in no way, is as hardcore about it as when he used to watch with his friend Catherine.
约翰在今年一月失业的时候，每天都要看四五个小时的《黑暗阴影》。现在他每周只看四个小时，而且只和朋友一起看。他现在一点也不像以前和朋友凯瑟琳一起看的时候那么狂热了。
Well, when Catherine was  here she insisted that we watch it. And it would be like hard to get her to stop, actually. I mean, honestly, it would. It would be like 12:00 midnight. And she'd go, please, one more, one more episode. And I'm like, you know, I've got to get up for work tomorrow. She's like, please, just one more. She'd be begging. It got really sad.
嗯，凯瑟琳在这里的时候，她坚持要我们看。说实话，那时候很难让她停下来。我是认真的，真的很难。那时候经常是半夜12点，她会说：“求你了，再看一集，就再看一集。”而我就说：“你知道的，我明天还得上班。”她就说：“求你了，就再看一集。”她会一直哀求。那情景真的很可怜。
Dark Shadows is slow. The sets are cheap. The writing is bad. The acting is stilted. It's a Gothic horror soap opera, produced five days a week from 1966 to '71. And, of course, it is not scary. It is never scary. Though when John was a kid, he was so scared of Dark Shadows , he'd get scared of the actresses lipstick, even the lipstick could do it.
《黑暗阴影》节奏很慢，布景很廉价，剧本很烂，表演也很生硬。这是一部哥特式恐怖肥皂剧，从1966年到1971年，每周制作五集。当然，它一点也不恐怖，从来都不恐怖。虽然约翰小时候看《黑暗阴影》时非常害怕，甚至连女演员的口红都能把他吓到。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , and it is the special Halloween edition of our program. Today we bring you stories of things that are supposed to be scary but are not. Act one, Dark Shadows . Act two, Scientist in a Haunted House. Act three, Vampire Girl. Act four, Discovering Evil. Act five, Gang Girl. And Act six, Screams. Those are your screams, your screams as left on our voicemail. I'm your ghost, I mean host, Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，今天是我们的万圣节特别节目。今天我们为您带来一些本该恐怖但实际上并不恐怖的故事。第一幕，《黑暗阴影》。第二幕，闹鬼房子里的科学家。第三幕，吸血鬼女孩。第四幕，发现邪恶。第五幕，帮派女孩。第六幕，尖叫。这些都是你们的尖叫，留在我们语音信箱里的尖叫。我是你们的鬼魂，哦不，是主持人，艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
What I learned at John's apartment about Dark Shadows is that the main point of it, the main pleasure of it, is watching things mess up. It's like watching car races for the car crashes. If the car crashes came every 10 minutes and nobody got hurt. This American Life producer Nancy Updike and I were in John's apartment for, I don't know, 10 minutes when a werewolf exited a scene, and through the open door, we could all witness this figure. Not a shadowy, mysterious figure from the year 1896, but instead--
我在约翰公寓里对《黑暗阴影》的了解是，它的核心，或者说主要乐趣，在于看它出错。就像为了看车祸而去观看赛车比赛一样。如果赛车每10分钟就出一次车祸，而且还没人受伤的话。我和《美国生活》的制作人南希·厄普代克在约翰的公寓里待了大概10分钟，就看到一个狼人离开了场景，透过敞开的门，我们都看到了这个身影。不是那种1896年神神秘秘的黑影，而是——
Oh, did you see the prop guy? Did you see the prop guy? Wait. Here look.
哦，你看到那个道具师了吗？你看到道具师了吗？等一下，你看。
Oh yeah.
噢，看到了。
A prop guy. There's a lot of rewinding and replaying this video, which John taped off the Sci-Fi Channel. John, and Thax, and Ericka  have watched actors forget lines, they've seen scripts left on beds, they've seen props fall over and smash. Periodically, there's an offstage cough. And what Thax describes as the sound of a giant zipper, mysterious, inexplicable, and not part of any story. When the vampire, Barnabas Collins, enters the foyer of Collinswood Manner, he closes the door behind him, and a moment later it swings open again.
一个道具师。约翰从科幻频道录下的这盘录像带里，有大量的快进和重播。约翰、萨克斯和艾丽卡经常看到演员忘词，看到剧本被丢在床上，看到道具倒下撞碎。时不时地还会听到幕后的咳嗽声，以及萨克斯所描述的像巨大拉链一样的声音，神秘、难以解释，而且和任何剧情无关。当吸血鬼巴纳巴斯·柯林斯进入柯林伍德庄园的门厅时，他随手关上了门，片刻之后，门又自己打开了。
Oh, there goes the door.
哦，门又开了。
Yeah, uh huh.
对，嗯哼。
There's something wrong with the lock on it. And it's always swinging open after somebody closes it.
它的锁出了点问题。每次有人关上门，它总是会自动弹开。
This is the kind of moment they live for. Giant tears in the fabric of the show's fantasy. John says that modern TV shows and movies are way too slick. What he likes are things that are either old, or imperfect, or both. His house is filled with huge sofa-like paintings that he's picked up at garage sales, and recordings where you can hear things fall over in the studio. A fast paced, modern film like Independence Day exhausts him with its relentlessly high production values. Dark Shadows is more human scale.
这正是他们最期待的时刻。剧集幻想外壳上的巨大裂痕。约翰说现代的电视节目和电影太圆滑了。他喜欢那些老旧的、不完美的，或者两者兼有的东西。他的房子里摆满了他在车库拍卖中淘来的沙发大小的画作，还有那些能听到摄影棚里东西倒塌声的录音。像《独立日》这样节奏飞快、制作精良的现代电影，其毫不留情的精良制作反而让他感到疲惫。《黑暗阴影》更具人性化。
Like you notice the littlest things you wouldn't notice in a regular show. We noticed tonight that people have stopped knocking on the door three times. They're now knocking on the door four times.
你会注意到那些在普通节目里根本不会留意的细节。我们今晚注意到，人们敲门不再敲三下了，现在他们敲四下。
I'll go out the back way.
我会从后门出去。
No, no you won't. You'll stay right here.
不，不，你不能走。你得待在这儿。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] they'll make me go back if they find-- [FOUR KNOCKS] [FOUR KNOCKS]
（听不清）如果他们发现……（敲四下）（敲四下）
So John thinks they had a lengthy meeting deciding that you have to have four knocks instead of three, to spice up the plot a little bit. It's more exciting.
所以约翰认为他们一定是开了一个漫长的会议，决定必须把敲门声改为四下而不是三下，好让剧情稍微精彩一点。这样更刺激。
Like the new director said, we've got to get rid of the old ways. Things are going to change around here. No more of this three knock stuff.
就像新导演说的那样，我们必须摒弃旧习。这儿的事情要变一变了，别再搞什么三下敲门了。
John is also sort of obsessed with trying to figure out exactly when the episodes were filmed. He claims that there is a point, in the 1969 episodes when, suddenly, all the characters started saying, groovy and freaky. By his calculations, the episodes that we're watching this night, were probably filmed in February 1969. One clue--
约翰还特别执着于研究这些剧集到底是什么时候拍摄的。他声称在1969年的剧集中，某个时间点所有角色突然开始说“groovy（时髦的）”和“freaky（怪异的）”。按照他的计算，我们今晚看的这些剧集大概是在1969年2月拍摄的。线索之一是——
Because in the summer, when it's summer, you can hear the air conditioner running.
因为夏天的时候，你可以听到空调的声音。
Yeah, and you see the flies.
对，而且你还能看到苍蝇。
And you see the flies. And I've never--
没错，能看到苍蝇。我从来没——
There's a lot of flies.
苍蝇实在太多了。
I mean, it's like the studio is next to an alley that had big garbage dumpsters, because there's always flies on the set. It's like the thing that's so amazing. There are scenes where flies are sitting all over people's faces, and they're pretending that they're not there.
我的意思是，就像摄影棚隔壁就是放着大垃圾桶的巷子一样，因为片场总是有苍蝇。这真的很神奇。有些场景里苍蝇都落在演员脸上，而他们还在假装那儿什么都没有。
It's kind of a character study, which actors decide to shoo the flies away, and which ones ignore them and continue bravely through the scenes.
这算是一种性格研究了，看哪些演员决定赶走苍蝇，哪些演员选择无视它们，勇敢地演完戏。
But the classic fly scene is like, when somebody was doing an exorcism, and the fly just went right into his mouth. So he just went [BLOWING SOUND] like that to get rid of it.
但经典的苍蝇场景是，当某人在做驱魔时，一只苍蝇直接飞进了他的嘴里。所以他只能这样（吹气声）把它弄出来。
What's interesting about all this is that not only does it defy the way you're supposed to watch horror films, it defies the way you're supposed to watch drama. They do not suspend disbelief for one second. Instead, they construct elaborate fantasies, not about the characters, but about the actors who play the characters.
关于这一切，有趣的地方不仅在于它违背了观看恐怖片的常理，也违背了观看剧情片的常理。他们一秒钟都没有入戏。相反，他们构建了复杂的幻想，不是针对角色，而是针对扮演角色的演员。
There's like a real vulnerability to all the characters. And even people that you don't like on the show, like the Chris Jennings character, he's this horrible actor, and that Beth character, she's like a horrible actress, but after a while you get really attached to them. Because you feel like you could just see her going off stage and going, oh my god. And people going, oh, you did really well today. There's a life behind it.
剧中所有角色都有种真实脆弱的感觉。即使是你不喜欢的角色，比如克里斯·詹宁斯，他是个蹩脚的演员；还有贝丝那个角色，她是个糟糕的演员；但久而久之你会对他们产生感情。因为你觉得你能看到她下了台后说“天哪”，然后大家说“哦，你今天演得真好”。这背后是有生活的。
What's the matter?
怎么了？
Jewell was murdered at school last night.
珠宝昨晚在学校被谋杀了。
What?
什么？
--from her teacher. Torn apart by a wild beast.
——从她老师那儿听来的，被野兽撕碎了。
Yes, it does seem a rather hideous way to die.
是的，这确实是一种极其可怕的死法。
I mean, I think Dark Shadows has a lot of Ed Wood to it. There's a lot of that sort of putting things together at the last minute. And putting your heart into something even though it's not very good, because I mean, it really does-- I've worked on really bad projects. You work just as hard on a bad project as you do on a good project.
我认为《黑暗阴影》有很多爱德·伍德（低成本电影导演）的风格。有很多那种最后一刻拼凑起来的感觉。哪怕东西并不怎么好，你还是会倾注心血，因为我真的——我做过非常糟糕的项目。你在烂项目上所付出的努力，和在好项目上是一样的。
[SOUNDS OF TERROR] It's so pointless. It's happening again. [SMALL MOTOR REVVING IN IMITATION OF WOLF GROWL] No. No. No. Don't come near me. [SCREAMS AND MOTOR SOUNDS/GROWLING]
（恐怖的声音）太没意义了。又发生了。（用嗓音模仿狼嚎的马达声）不。不。不。别靠近我。（尖叫声、马达声和咆哮声）
John's favorite actress is Grayson Hall, who plays Magda and Julia, and who, inexplicably, enters a lot of scenes sniffing the air, as if there is some bad odor that's never discussed or explained.
约翰最喜欢的演员是格雷森·霍尔，她饰演玛格达和朱莉娅。她有个无法解释的习惯，就是进场时经常吸着鼻子，好像闻到了某种从未讨论或解释过的恶臭。
I know nothing about her. I know absolutely nothing about this woman as an actress except for what she does. But I have this whole sense of what she does after the show. I have this whole world that I've built up around her.
我对她一无所知。除了她在剧里的表现，作为一名演员，我对这个女人一无所知。但我对她下戏后的生活有一种完整的感觉，我围绕她构建了一个完整的世界。
Yeah, me too.
我也是。
What does she do after the show?
她下戏后做什么？
Well, I just think she sits in a bar and drinks and smokes cigarettes. She's just like one of these people--
嗯，我猜她就是坐在酒吧里喝酒、抽烟。她就是那种人——
All right. I was angry. I put the curse on you. I said it would be a terrible curse.
好吧，我很生气。我给你下了咒。我说那会是一个可怕的诅咒。
Yeah, she's got the most incredible facial expressions of any actress I've ever seen. I don't think I've ever seen anybody who's face fascinates me more than Grayson Hall. I don't know. She should have been a huge star.
是的，她的面部表情是我见过所有演员中最不可思议的。我觉得我从没见过比格雷森·霍尔更让我着迷的脸。我不知道，她本该成为超级巨星的。
You mean, she's good?
你是说她演得好？
Well, no that's just it. See--
不，关键就在这儿。你看——
Somewhere during the second episode of the night, I realized that, not only are these stories convoluted and hard to follow, they're incredibly boring, boring in a way that invites speculation and embroidery by the audience. For instance, the reliable father figure in this program is Barnabas Collins. And he's supposed to be this really great guy, and everybody loves him, and he's always jumping in and saving people. So why is he a vampire? Thax says it can be sort of disconcerting at times.
那天晚上看到第二集的时候，我意识到这些故事不仅错综复杂、难以理解，而且极其无聊，这种无聊反而邀请观众去猜测和添油加醋。例如，剧里可靠的父亲形象是巴纳巴斯·柯林斯。他本该是个好人，大家都爱他，总是出手救人。那他为什么是个吸血鬼呢？萨克斯说这有时会让人感到困惑。
Like you love Barnabas, and they just casually mention how he kills village girls to get his blood.
就像你很喜欢巴纳巴斯，但他们又漫不经心地提到他为了获取血液杀害了村里的女孩。
It's like you're supposed just go, oh--
就像你被要求只能说“噢——”
Oh, that Barnabas, right.
噢，是那个巴纳巴斯，没错。
I mean, every so often he goes into the village. Doesn't everybody go in the village once in a while, and--
我的意思是，他时不时就去村里一趟。难道不是每个人都会偶尔去村里走走吗，然后——
It takes a village.
那得需要一个村庄。
Pretty soon after this, John declares that he has a Dark Shadows bloopers reel, full of funny accidents from the show. He spends the next hour searching among maybe 50 badly labeled tapes for it, popping in one obscure video after another. At one point he shows us a video that he made of a macrame clown sort of dancing in a darkened room to a mysterious song. He never finds the bloopers reel. And, at a certain point, I realize the entire evening has come to resemble a Dark Shadows episode itself, slow moving, full of accidents, convoluted, but really kind of fun.
没过多久，约翰宣布他有一盘《黑暗阴影》的失误集锦，里面全是剧里好笑的事故。他接下来的一个小时都在50盘贴着乱七八糟标签的录像带里翻找，不停地插入各种冷门的录像。有一刻他给我们看了一段他自己制作的录像，一个花边小丑在黑暗的房间里伴随着神秘的音乐跳舞。他最终没找到那盘失误集锦。而在某一刻，我意识到整个晚上变得就像《黑暗阴影》的一集——节奏缓慢、充满事故、错综复杂，但实际上还挺有趣的。
Thax flips to the Polish videos channel and talks about the Polish Beatles movie he once saw. And John explains his plan to attend his first Dark Shadows convention in a month or two. It's strange, John says, how a TV show that once seemed like the biggest thing in the world could be so obscure now. It makes you think about Madonna, and ER, and The X Files , and what anyone's going to remember 30 years from now.
萨克斯换到了播放波兰视频的频道，讲起他曾经看过的波兰版披头士电影。约翰解释了他打算在这一两个月内去参加他人生中的第一次《黑暗阴影》粉丝大会。约翰说，一个曾经看起来像全世界最重大的电视节目，现在居然变得这么冷门，这真奇怪。这让你想到麦当娜、《急诊室的故事》和《X档案》，想到30年后还有谁会记得这些。
I know what the last line of Dark Shadows is. And I think they were going to go back and do another werewolf plot line or something like that, and then they got canceled. And the last line is, the marks on such and so's neck were discovered to be just an animal, and not anything having to do with the supernatural.
我知道《黑暗阴影》的最后一集台词是什么。我想他们原本打算回去做另一个狼人剧情线什么的，结果被取消了。最后的台词是：“某某脖子上的印记被发现只是一只动物造成的，与任何超自然现象无关。”
And I was talking to this guy, and he was like completely into Dark Shadows when he was young. And he told me this story about when him and his brother used to just watch Dark Shadows religiously. And it was the last show, and they say the line about, everyone lives happily ever after, and then they're showing the credits. And then the announcer comes on and says, next Monday at this time, stay tuned for Password with Allen Ludden. And he said, his brother screamed at the screen. You bastard! You bastard!
我曾经和一个家伙谈过，他年轻时完全迷上了《黑暗阴影》。他告诉我，他和弟弟曾经像信徒一样虔诚地观看《黑暗阴影》。那是最后一场演出，当他们说完那句“每个人从此幸福地生活在一起”之后，画面开始显示演职员表。然后播音员跑出来说：“下周一同一时间，请继续收看艾伦·勒登的《密码》节目。”他说，他弟弟对着屏幕尖叫道：“你这混蛋！你这混蛋！”
In a certain sense, things that are scary have a lot in common really with  things that are funny. A, they both produce a physical reaction. And B, if something that is supposed to be scary fails to be scary, it's way more funny than something that's trying to be funny, if that makes sense.
从某种意义上说，恐怖的事情和有趣的事情确实有很多共同点。第一，它们都会产生身体反应。第二，如果一件本该恐怖的事情失败了，它反而会比那些试图搞笑的东西更加好笑，如果这说得通的话。
It sort of goes without saying, but this is our Halloween show, so I'm going to say this anyway, that for John, and for Thax, and for Ericka, nothing about Dark Shadows has anything to do with things that are scary, with ghouls or spooks or Halloween. They could care less about Halloween.
这可能不用说大家也知道，但毕竟这是我们的万圣节节目，我还是得提一下：对于约翰、萨克斯和艾丽卡来说，《黑暗阴影》和恐怖、鬼怪或万圣节毫无关系。他们根本不在乎万圣节。
So what are you guys doing for Halloween?
那么你们万圣节打算做什么？
Well, Halloween's my birthday, so I don't like to dress up.
嗯，万圣节正好是我生日，所以我不喜欢装扮。
That's Thax. Here's Ericka.
那是萨克斯。这是艾丽卡。
What am I going to do on Halloween? I don't know. Probably nothing. I painted a pumpkin so far, but that's probably about it.
万圣节我能做什么？我不知道。大概什么也不做吧。到目前为止我只画了一个南瓜，但也仅此而已了。
And finally, John, who hates Halloween, because it's a day when you're expected to be creative.
最后是约翰，他讨厌万圣节，因为这一天你被要求要有创造力。
I have my monkey hair cape. I wore that last year. Do you know what monkey hair-- it's made out of monkeys. And I guess like in the '40s, they outlawed it, because they were killing monkeys to make these coats. And they're beautiful coats. I mean, they're insane. And they were real popular in the '20s, and if you--
我有我的猴毛斗篷。去年我穿了那件。你知道什么是猴毛吗——它是用猴子做的。我猜大概在40年代，这种东西就被取缔了，因为他们为了做这种大衣杀害猴子。那是非常漂亮的大衣。我是说，它们太疯狂了。在20年代非常流行，如果你——
Act Two, Haunted House. You know can't do a Halloween show without at least one truly spooky story. And this one we have fits the bill pretty well. But, of course, in keeping with our pledge that everything that is supposed to be scary about Halloween will be rendered harmless during our program today, what we are bringing you is a spooky story that happens to somebody who is completely unafraid, totally unafraid, could care less. A woman named Carol Estler moved into an old house in Massachusetts in the 1970s. And in this story you're going to hear her and her daughter describe what happened.
第二幕，鬼屋。你知道，没有至少一个真正令人毛骨悚然的故事，就不能称之为万圣节节目。我们要讲的这个非常符合要求。但当然，为了兑现我们“今天节目中所有本该恐怖的内容都将变得无害”的承诺，我们将为您带来一个发生在完全不害怕、一点也不害怕的人身上的灵异故事。一位名叫卡罗尔·埃斯特勒的女士在70年代搬进了马萨诸塞州的一座老房子里。在这个故事中，你将听到她和她的女儿描述发生了什么。
At first they noticed these patches of wavy air, like when you see heat rise off a barbecue grill. And they heard sounds, people walking, stuff clattering around, when there was nobody around. Once Carol was walking to the barn, and suddenly she says, there was a just a wall in front of her, just this force, this force blocking her way. And she said she waited, and eventually it went away. And she didn't tell anybody about it.
起初他们注意到了一些空气波动，就像从烤架上冒出的热气。他们还听到了声音，有人走动、东西碰撞，但周围明明没人。有一次卡罗尔正走去谷仓，突然她说，前面有一道墙，有一股力量挡住了她的去路。她说她等了一会儿，后来那力量消失了。她没告诉任何人。
And a few days later, her daughter ran into the kitchen and said she was walking to the barn, and an invisible wall blocked her way. Carol Estler was a professional scientist, and she tried to find other explanations for what was happening other than ghosts. But the data all started to point in one direction.
几天后，她的女儿跑进厨房说，她去谷仓的时候，有一堵隐形的墙挡住了她。卡罗尔·埃斯特勒是一名专业科学家，她试图寻找除鬼魂之外的其他合理解释。但所有数据都指向了同一个方向。
One night, I was lying in my bed, and I was just about ready to fall asleep. And the strangest thing was that I suddenly felt my body start to move. It was like, if you could imagine your body was magnetic, and someone was taking a magnet and sort of moving it slowly around your body, and was pulling in kind of a broad gentle way, one way and then the other.
一天晚上，我躺在床上，正要入睡。最奇怪的是，我突然感觉到自己的身体开始移动。就像——如果你能想象你的身体是有磁性的，有人拿着一块磁铁，在你的身体周围缓慢移动，以一种宽广而温和的方式拉扯，这一会儿，那一会儿。
It really felt like my body was being pulled from the outside. And I'm a scientist, so I watched. And I watched, and I got wide awake. And I watched that for almost two hours as my body was sort of pulled one way, then pulled the other way, really a very strange feeling. And I was getting really, really tired. Somehow that pulling was just making me so tired. So I thought I'd try an experiment. And I said, out loud, look I'm really, really tired. Will you please stop? And it stopped.
那种感觉就像我的身体从外面被拉扯。我是个科学家，所以我观察。我观察着，人变得非常清醒。我观察了近两个小时，看着我的身体被拉向这边，又拉向那边，这感觉真的很奇怪。我变得非常、非常疲惫。不知何故，那种拉扯让我感到极度疲倦。所以我决定做一个实验。我大声说：“听着，我真的、真的非常累。请你停下来，好吗？”然后它就停了。
Now I don't know that I ever really talked to anything. I don't really know what was there. It was just a very strange experience. But still, we kept trying to find other explanations. And for me, I stopped trying to find other explanations when, one night, I woke up, I don't know why, and I just looked across the room, and there was a woman standing there. And she was just standing. She was looking around at things. She wasn't looking at me. She wasn't looking at anything that seemed to be in the room. She seemed to be looking far off. And then she turned, and she walked out of the room, right through the closed door.
现在我不知道我是否真的和什么东西交谈过。我不知道那是什么。那只是一个非常奇怪的经历。但尽管如此，我们一直在努力寻找其他的解释。对我来说，我停止寻找其他解释是在某天晚上，我醒了过来，不知道为什么，我只是向房间对面望去，有一个女人站在那里。她只是站在那儿。她看着周围的东西，她没看我。她没看房间里的任何东西。她看起来是在凝视远方。然后她转过身，穿过那扇关着的门走出了房间。
I thought about that for a while, quite a while. And I think I've pretty much accepted now that I live in a house where there are ghosts, leftover pieces of other people who don't really see me, because the woman didn't seem to see me or anything in the room. Sometimes, I can see them. Sometimes they can move things and move me in ways that I can feel or see. Sometimes they can make noises. They certainly don't seem to be trying to bother us. I suppose, maybe, even they experience us as ghosts, because we probably look invisible to them, the way she couldn't see me. It's a very interesting house to live in.
我想了很久很久。我想我现在基本上接受了这一点：我住的房子里有鬼魂，是其他人的残留碎片，他们并不真正看到我，因为那个女人似乎没看到我或房间里的任何东西。有时，我能看见他们。有时他们能移动东西，以我能感觉到或看到的方式移动我。有时他们会制造噪音。他们当然看起来并不想打扰我们。我想，也许他们也把我们当成鬼魂，因为在他们看来我们可能是隐形的，就像她看不见我一样。住在这栋房子里很有趣。
The important one I haven't mentioned yet is the crying baby. I have not experienced the crying baby, although she is said to spend a lot of time in my room. The first time someone experienced it, they were sleeping in the small room off of mine. It was a guest. And there were no children in the house that night. And the next morning he said, where was the child crying all night long? I heard a child crying all night long.
我还没提到的重要一点是那个哭泣的婴儿。我没经历过婴儿哭泣，虽然据说她花了很多时间在我的房间里。第一次有人经历这件事时，他们睡在我房间旁边的小屋里。那是一位客人。那天晚上家里没有孩子。第二天早上他说：“整晚哭个不停的孩子在哪儿？我听见有个孩子哭了一整晚。”
There's an old foundation on the back part of the property, which is supposed to have dated back from a house in Revolutionary times or earlier, which had burnt here and, supposedly, burnt in it was a woman and a child.
房子的后部有一个古老的地基，据说可以追溯到革命战争时期或更早，那里曾经有一座房子被烧毁，据说里面烧死了一名妇女和一个孩子。
Certainly, I had no training in anything like that. I come from three generations of scientists, and ghosts just don't fit. But if you're a real scientist, into research, then one of the most basic parts of you is the principle that everything you know is wrong. Every theory, every model, somehow breaks down. And it doesn't matter whether it's quantum mechanics, or nuclear physics, or super conductivity, in some way or other, the model is incomplete. In some way or the other, the model is wrong.
当然，我没有任何这方面的训练。我来自三代科学世家，鬼魂根本说不通。但如果你是一个真正搞研究的科学家，你最基本的一点就是“你所知道的一切可能都是错的”。每一个理论、每一个模型，最终都会崩塌。无论是量子力学、核物理还是超导，模型总是不完整的。某种程度上，模型总是有误的。
And the way you learn, in science, is to keep pushing your models until you find out where they're wrong. And I think, living here in this house, I've got some new models in my science.
在科学中学习的方式，就是不断推敲你的模型，直到发现它们错在哪里。我想，住在这个房子里，我的科学观里多了一些新的模型。
[MUSIC - DARK SHADOWS ALBUM]
（音乐 - 《黑暗阴影》专辑）
Well, this song is Barnabas Collins himself, the friendly, fatherly vampire, as played by Jonathan Frid, from the Dark Shadows album.
嗯，这首歌就是巴纳巴斯·柯林斯本人，那位友善、慈祥的吸血鬼，由乔纳森·弗里德在《黑暗阴影》专辑中演唱。
[MUSIC - DARK SHADOWS ALBUM]
（音乐 - 《黑暗阴影》专辑）
Act Three, Vampire Girl.
第三幕，吸血鬼女孩。
My character is Lady Cassandra, and Lady Cassandra is a vampire. The Lady Cassandra is basically walking, talking sex.
我的角色是卡桑德拉夫人，她是个吸血鬼。卡桑德拉夫人基本上就是行走的、会说话的欲望。
It's not just that fear is close to laughter, it's also close to sex. Shawna Kennedy plays Lady Cassandra at Haunted Verdun Manor, this huge, annual haunted house and more in Terrell, Texas, about 30 miles outside Dallas. Like Carol Estler, that woman who lives in a haunted house, Shawna is also a scientist, who found a new model for looking at the world. And Shawna Kennedy was always sort of shy. She didn't like scary movies. She didn't like horror novels. She'd never been to a haunted house until last year. And last year, she made a big, big turnaround. Now, every night, she goes out to Haunted Verdun Manor to--
恐惧不仅仅接近笑声，它也接近性。肖娜·肯尼迪在得克萨斯州特雷尔（达拉斯外约30英里处）的“闹鬼凡尔登庄园”里扮演卡桑德拉夫人，这是一个巨大的年度鬼屋。和住在闹鬼房子里的卡罗尔·埃斯特勒一样，肖娜也是一名科学家，她找到了一种看待世界的新模式。肖娜·肯尼迪曾经很内向。她不喜欢恐怖电影，不喜欢恐怖小说。直到去年她才第一次去鬼屋。去年，她经历了一个巨大的转变。现在，每天晚上她都会去凡尔登庄园——
Roam the grounds, looking for victims. And we basically try to physically and psychologically torment the people waiting in line to get into the house.
在场地上游荡，寻找受害者。我们基本上试图在心理和生理上折磨那些在队里等着进鬼屋的人。
Like how?
怎么折磨？
Oh, we stalk them. We will look at the crowd and try to pick the one most likely to give a good fear reaction. And we try to get that person's attention, from a good distance. And then, very, very slowly creep up on them, maintaining eye contact, never breaking the stare. And this is usually enough to give us a good scream, or squeal, or at least a break and run out of the line.
哦，我们跟踪他们。我们会观察人群，挑选出最有可能产生强烈恐惧反应的人。我们试图从远处引起那个人的注意，然后非常、非常缓慢地靠近，保持目光接触，绝不移开视线。这通常足以让我们听到尖叫、惊呼，或者至少看到有人吓得跑出队列。
And are you shooting for a break and run?
你们是想看他们吓得跑掉吗？
That's always good. It's very entertaining for everyone else in the line. A scream is also good. We like a good scream.
那当然好。这对排队的其他人来说非常娱乐。尖叫也很好，我们喜欢好的尖叫。
What do you wear?
你穿什么？
[LAUGHS] I wear a skintight, black velvet dress, with a slit almost all the way up one leg.
（笑）我穿一件紧身的黑色天鹅绒裙子，腿部开叉开到大腿根。
What do you say to men and women when you walk up to them.
你走近男人或女人时会对他们说什么？
I don't say anything.
我什么都不说。
You don't talk at all.
你根本不说话？
I talk as little as possible.
我尽可能少说话。
How come?
为什么？
Because people in power don't need to say a lot. So if you say as little as possible, it gives people the impression that you are more powerful than they might necessarily feel.
因为掌握权力的人不需要多说话。如果你说得越少，就越会让人们觉得你比他们想象中更有力量。
And how does this compare to who you are when you're not playing Cassandra?
这和你扮演卡桑德拉之外的身份相比如何？
Oh, I'm a science geek. I work in a laboratory. I play with DNA. I'm just as happy being in the back corner of the lab, by myself, doing whatever.
哦，我是个科学极客。我在实验室工作。我摆弄DNA。我更喜欢独自待在实验室角落里，做我自己的事。
Wardrobe of your daily life? What do you wear in the daytime?
你平时的穿着呢？白天穿什么？
Jeans and a sweatshirt. At night, my clothing will get more flamboyant. Also I'm a belly dancer, so my costuming for that is pretty flamboyant.
牛仔裤和运动衫。晚上，我的衣服会变得更华丽。另外我还是个肚皮舞者，所以我的演出服装相当华丽。
Why do you like scaring people?
你为什么喜欢吓唬人？
It's an amazing feeling of power to know that, here you are, somebody that generally, in my geek girl uniform, and my glasses, and my hair pulled back in a little top knot, I wouldn't make anybody look twice at me. But as Cassandra, not only are they looking twice at me, but some of them are actually running from me. And I like that. That's fun.
这是一种惊人的力量感，你知道，作为一个平时穿着极客装、戴着眼镜、头发扎成小揪的人，我根本不会吸引任何人的目光。但作为卡桑德拉，不仅有人看我，甚至有人被我吓得逃跑。我喜欢那样，那很有趣。
This is a question I'm not sure how exactly to ask. But I want to ask it, and I'm sure it's something that you might have thought about, given the way that you're costumed when you do this. What is a connection between sex and Halloween, between sex and scaring people?
我不确定该怎么问这个问题，但我很想问。考虑到你扮演这个角色时的装束，我想这大概是你思考过的问题：性和万圣节之间，性和吓唬人之间，有什么联系？
The sexual response and the fear response in human beings is similar-- increased heart rate and respiratory rate.
人类的性反应和恐惧反应是相似的——心率和呼吸频率都会增加。
See, now you're sounding like the science geek.
你看，你现在听起来就像个科学极客了。
Similarities in the way your body responds to both fear and sex. Also, some of the images that we have in Western culture of things that are horrific are also basically sexual.
身体对恐惧和性反应的方式有相似之处。此外，西方文化中一些恐怖的意象本质上也是性的。
Like what?
比如什么？
The werewolf is the beast within. And, basically, vampirism is just sex from the neck up. You're penetrating a passive person. It really is a very sexual sort of monster.
狼人是内心的野兽。而吸血鬼本质上就是颈部以上的性。你正在渗透一个被动的人。这确实是一种非常性的怪物。
So when you're wandering the grounds, do you feel like it's one intense little seduction after another?
所以当你在场地游荡时，你觉得这是一种强烈的诱惑吗？
Absolutely.
绝对是。
Compare the sexuality of doing Cassandra to the sexuality of doing belly dancing.
比较一下扮演卡桑德拉的性感和跳肚皮舞的性感。
The sexuality of Cassandra is dark. She always will have that underlying element of, I could have sex with you or I could kill you. With belly dancing, it is a joyful thing. It is, this is my body, and this is how moves, and isn't it great that it moves this way? Aren't you enjoying this?
卡桑德拉的性感是黑暗的。她总是有一种潜在的元素：“我可以和你发生关系，也可以杀了你”。而跳肚皮舞是一种快乐的东西。它是：“这就是我的身体，它是这样移动的，这样移动不是很棒吗？你不享受这个吗？”
Are they equally sexual experiences to perform?
它们是同样性感的表演体验吗？
Absolutely. Absolutely.
绝对是。绝对是。
That's incredible.
太不可思议了。
Absolutely.
绝对是。
Shawna says that she hated scary stuff until a few years ago, when she read this Stephen King book, Dance Macabre . Which makes the case that everybody needs a good scare now and then, and that all cultures have some version of ghost stories to do this. And reading that set her on this path that eventually led to her playing Lady Cassandra. And she says that playing Lady Cassandra sped up this process that she thinks would have happened anyway in her adult life, of learning to be more assertive. She says it's also given her a more complicated picture of herself than she had when she was a kid.
肖娜说她直到几年前读了斯蒂芬·金的《死之舞》才不再讨厌恐怖的东西。那本书认为每个人都需要偶尔受到良好的惊吓，而且所有文化都有某种形式的鬼故事来达到这个目的。阅读那本书让她踏上了那条最终导致她扮演卡桑德拉夫人的道路。她说，扮演卡桑德拉加速了她成年后必然会发生的这一过程——即学习变得更加自信。她说这也给了她一个比小时候更复杂的自我形象。
I saw myself before as being a good Baptist girl, a complete creature of goodness, who was going to be tormented by the powers of darkness. Afterwards, I see myself as a creature of both light and dark. I have both elements in me. And I sort of got the idea that I really wasn't going to go to Hell for it, for having a dark side. It was no longer threatening to me.
以前我把自己看作是一个善良的浸信会女孩，一个完全纯洁的造物，注定要被黑暗力量折磨。后来，我把自己看作是一个光明与黑暗共存的造物。我身上既有光明也有黑暗。我开始觉得，我并不会因为有阴暗面而下地狱。这对我来说不再是一种威胁。
And this brings us to our next story. This is a story about another Texas girl discovering her dark side. We have arrived at Act [? Three ?] of our program, The Evil Within. And we are pleased to welcome back to This American Life , writer Julie Showalter.
这就引出了我们的下一个故事。这是另一个得克萨斯女孩发现她阴暗面的故事。我们来到了本节目的第四幕，《内心的邪恶》。我们很高兴欢迎作家朱莉·肖沃尔特回到《美国生活》。
I was raised a Baptist, a Southern Baptist in west Texas. So I always knew that I was a sinner. But it wasn't until Halloween day in the fourth grade that I thought of myself as a sinful being. Before that, sin was something that could be overcome through hard work, prayer, reading the Bible, and thinking of a way out of coveting Tommy Sue Bailey's new Madame Alexander doll. Afterwards, I knew sin was part of me, in every molecule of my body, and I could never get rid of it.
我是在得克萨斯州西部的浸信会环境中长大的。所以我一直知道我是个罪人。但在四年级的万圣节那天之前，我还没真正想过自己是个罪恶的人。在那之前，罪可以通过努力工作、祈祷、读圣经，以及想办法不再贪图汤米·苏·贝利的新玛达姆·亚历山大娃娃来克服。那之后，我知道罪是我身体里每个分子的一部分，我永远也无法摆脱它。
I was very excited about going to school on Halloween day. Mother had decided I could look like Daisy Mae Yokum, Lil' Abner's wife in the funny papers. She cut off and fringed a pair of old jeans. She found a peasant blouse, which we ripped, then pinned together with a diaper pin. She put my hair in pigtails and painted freckles on my nose. When she finished, she said, you look so cute. Let's take a picture to send your daddy.
我对万圣节去学校感到非常兴奋。妈妈决定让我打扮成 Daisy Mae Yokum，连环画里利尔·阿布纳的妻子。她剪掉了一条旧牛仔裤并做成了流苏。她找到一件农妇上衣，我们把它撕破，然后用尿布别针别在一起。她把我的头发扎成辫子，还在我的鼻子上画了雀斑。她做好后说：“你看起来太可爱了。让我们拍张照寄给你爸爸。”
Daddy lived 80 miles away in Amarillo. He visited pretty often now, and he and mother wrote letters. I smiled my best smile for the picture, a smile that would show daddy what a good, pretty girl I was and, make him want to come home to stay.
爸爸住在80英里外的阿马里洛。他现在经常回来，他和妈妈会写信。我对着照片露出了我最灿烂的笑容，这个笑容会让爸爸看到我是一个多么好、多么漂亮的女孩，让他想回家永远待着。
The next day, I went to school bare-legged, bare-footed, bare-shouldered, knowing that about half my friends would have ripped up one of their father's old dress shirts and come as bums, and the other half would have dug out old cowboy guns and cowboy hats and called that a costume. I thought I had a chance at the prize. I imagined my teacher's reaction. Janice, you're just the cutest thing, she'd say, and so clever. Maybe she'd hug me, like she did sometimes.
第二天，我光着腿、光着脚、光着肩膀去上学，想着我的一半朋友大概会撕碎父亲的旧衬衫装成流浪汉，另一半会翻出旧玩具枪戴上牛仔帽。我觉得我很有机会拿奖。我幻想老师的反应。她会说：“贾妮丝，你真是最可爱的，而且太聪明了。”也许她会像平时那样抱抱我。
Mrs. Wells was the first teacher I idolized. She was young and pretty, sweet and vivacious. She dressed in pastels and smelled like cotton candy. She had just married, and her husband was a part-time football coach and a part-time Baptist minister. For a while, I wished my mother would die and she'd adopt me, but I realized that was a sinful thought. So I wished there was some kind of big sister organization, and she'd be my big sister, and maybe my mother would decide I should live with her, because she lived closer to church or something.
韦尔斯太太是我崇拜的第一个老师。她年轻漂亮，甜美活泼。她穿着柔和色调的衣服，闻起来像棉花糖。她刚结婚，丈夫是一名兼职橄榄球教练和兼职浸信会牧师。有一段时间，我希望妈妈死掉，这样她就能领养我，但我意识到这是一个罪恶的想法。所以我希望有什么姐妹组织，她能当我的姐姐，或者妈妈可能会决定让我和她住，因为她住得离教堂更近什么的。
On Halloween, I stopped just inside the classroom door, waiting for her to see me, posing a little, excited for her reaction. When she turned, her mouth dropped open. Janice Ray Hopewell, what are you thinking of? That outfit is indecent, it's obscene. You look like a little temptress. Why, you're practically naked.
万圣节那天，我停在教室门口，等着她看见我，摆了个姿势，期待着她的反应。当她转过身时，嘴巴张大了。 “贾妮丝·雷·霍普威尔，你在想什么？那套衣服太不雅了，太猥亵了。你看上去就像个小妖女。你简直是赤身裸体。”
A temptress? Naked? I didn't know I was naked. Then I thought of Adam and Eve in the Garden of Eden, and how they didn't know they were naked. I looked down at my feet and legs and saw them as the feet and legs of a naked temptress. While Mrs. Wells talked to me, she pulled Ernesto Rodriguez's chair to the back. Janice, sit down in the corner. No, not at your desk. It's right in front where anyone walking by can see you. Sit in the back here. Patsy, get the blanket out of the closet. She can cover herself with that.
妖女？赤身裸体？我不知道我赤身裸体。然后我想到伊甸园里的亚当和夏娃，他们当初不知道自己是赤身裸体的。我低头看着自己的脚和腿，看着它们作为一个赤身裸体的妖女的脚和腿。当韦尔斯太太对我说话时，她把埃内斯托·罗德里格斯的椅子拉到了后面。“贾妮丝，坐在角落里。不，不是你的座位。那里就在前面，路过的人都能看见你。坐到后面的这里。帕特茜，把柜子里的毯子拿出来。她可以盖住自己。”
Leon, go get the principal, tell him it's an emergency. Cover up Janice, you'll cause sinful thoughts. I wrapped the blanket around myself. I remembered asking my Sunday school teacher, how could it've been all bad for Adam and Eve to eat the apple, since they got knowledge of good and evil, not just evil? And she said, they really just got knowledge of evil, everything had been good up to then. I pulled my feet up under the blanket.
“莱昂，去叫校长，告诉他这是紧急情况。遮住贾妮丝，你会引起淫念的。”我把毯子裹在自己身上。我记得我曾问过主日学老师，亚当和夏娃吃苹果怎么可能是完全坏的，因为他们获得了分辨善恶的知识，不仅仅是恶？她说，他们确实只是获得了恶的知识，在那之前一切都是美好的。我把脚缩进毯子里。
The principal came in with Leon Anderson right behind him. What is it, Mrs. Wells? Is one of the children hurt? Mrs. Wells blushed. I guess it's not really an urgent emergency. I just felt we had to do something right away. Janice show him your costume. I couldn't believe it. She'd said I was naked, and now she wanted me to show the principal and the whole class.
校长带着莱昂·安德森进来了。“怎么了，韦尔斯太太？孩子们受伤了吗？”韦尔斯太太脸红了。“我想这并不真的是紧急情况。我只是觉得我们必须立刻做点什么。贾妮丝，给他看看你的服装。”我不敢相信。她说我赤身裸体，现在又想让我给校长和全班看。
Janice Ray, take that blanket off. I stood up and put the blanket on the chair behind me. I looked at the floor. After a minute, the principal said, well, there is a requirement that children wear shoes to school for health reasons, but if she stays off the playground, I don't think anything will happen in just one day. Janice, you tell your mother that your costume next year has to include shoes.
“贾妮丝·雷，把毯子拿下来。”我站起来，把毯子放在身后的椅子上。我盯着地板。过了一会儿，校长说：“嗯，从健康角度考虑，确实有要求孩子穿鞋上学的规定，但如果她待在教室不出操场，我认为只待一天不会有什么事。贾妮丝，告诉你妈妈你明年的服装里必须包括鞋子。”
Mrs. Wells grabbed his arm. Can I talk to you in the hall. I could see them talking outside the door as I put the blanket back around me. At first the principal looked like something was funny. But Mrs. Wells didn't calm down. Then he looked mad and did the rest of the talking.
韦尔斯太太抓住他的胳膊。“我能和你去走廊谈谈吗？”我看到他们站在门外谈话，我把毯子重新裹回身上。起初校长看起来觉得这事挺滑稽。但韦尔斯太太没有冷静下来。后来他看起来很生气，说了剩下的话。
When Mrs. Wells came back in, she walked over to me and jerked the blanket away. Janice, give me the blanket. It seems I have overreacted. Her face was red, and she sounded like she was reciting a lesson. She didn't look at me. There's nothing inappropriate about your costume, although bare feet are extremely unhygienic. Go to your regular seat.
当韦尔斯太太回来时，她走向我，猛地扯掉毯子。“贾妮丝，把毯子给我。”她脸红了，听起来像是在背诵课文。她没看我。“你的服装没什么不合适的，尽管光脚极不卫生。回到你的座位上去。”
Can I keep the blanket? No, you may not keep the blanket. There's absolutely nothing wrong with your costume. In fact, I think you should stand up in front of the class, so we'll all have a chance to look at it. It will be good for all of us to see what's acceptable, so we don't overreact again.
“我可以保留毯子吗？”“不，你不能保留。你的服装绝对没问题。事实上，我觉得你应该站在班级前面，好让大家都看一看。这对我们大家来说都很好，可以看到什么是可以接受的，这样我们就不会再反应过度了。”
For 15 minutes, she made me stand there, while the other kids looked at me and giggled behind their hands. I thought about all the temptresses I knew, about Bathsheba, and Delilah, and about Salome who danced nearly naked so they'd cut off John the Baptist's head. I thought of the movie ads with Carol Baker in baby-doll pajamas sucking her thumb, that all the preachers were mad about. And I thought about Marilyn Monroe with her skirt blowing up, looking happy. And how everyone said, Joe DiMaggio had divorced her because her skirt blew up.
她让我站在那儿15分钟，其他孩子看着我，在手后面窃窃私语。我想到我知道的所有妖女，想到拔示巴，想到大利拉，想到莎乐美，她跳了近乎裸体的舞，好让人砍下施洗约翰的头。我想到卡罗尔·贝克穿着婴儿娃娃睡衣吸着大拇指的电影广告，所有传教士都为此愤怒。我想到玛丽莲·梦露裙子被吹起，看起来很快乐的样子。大家说，乔·迪马乔和她离婚就是因为她的裙子吹起来了。
And if part of me was excited that I could be a temptress like Eve, and Bathsheba, and Delilah, and Salome, and Carol Baker, and Marilyn Monroe, and maybe even like Elizabeth Taylor, most of me was horrified that I was sinful, and causing sin in others without even knowing how or why. It was just something I was, not something I did or even thought.
如果说我的一部分因为能成为像夏娃、拔示巴、大利拉、莎乐美、卡罗尔·贝克、玛丽莲·梦露，甚至伊丽莎白·泰勒那样的妖女而感到兴奋，那么我大部分是被自己竟然如此罪恶、甚至不知道原因就引起他人犯罪而感到恐惧。这只是我的一部分，不是我做了什么或想了什么。
I thought of Daddy seeing the picture of me, nearly naked, and I knew I had ruined everything. He wouldn't think I was a good sweet girl anymore. No one who knew about the costume would ever think I was a good girl again.
我想到爸爸看到我那张近乎赤身裸体的照片，我知道我毁了一切。他再也不会认为我是个好孩子了。任何知道这套衣服的人再也不会认为我是个好女孩了。
I got to spend the whole day at school bare-legged, bare-footed, bare-shouldered, feeling totally naked. At recess and lunch, I rushed to the bathroom, locked myself in a stall, and pulled my feet up so their nakedness wouldn't show.
我在学校里度过了整整一天，光着腿、光着脚、光着肩膀，感觉完全赤裸。课间休息和午餐时，我冲进洗手间，把自己锁在隔间里，把脚抬起来，这样它们的赤裸就不会露出来。
The next time Daddy came to see us, I was embarrassed and stayed in my room. And six months later, when Jimmy [? Rigga ?] pulled me into an alley and kissed me, I let him, even though I liked Leon Anderson. And the next day, I saw Jimmy whispering to Leon and knew they were talking about me. And two years later, when the principal at my new school got the sixth grade girls alone in the closet and rubbed all up and down our fronts, I was the only one who didn't tell her mother. Because he was a deacon at the First Baptist Church, and I was a temptress.
爸爸下次来看我们时，我很尴尬，躲在房间里。六个月后，当吉米·里加把我拉进小巷亲吻我时，我任由他亲吻，尽管我其实喜欢莱昂·安德森。第二天，我看到吉米在向莱昂耳语，我知道他们在谈论我。两年后，当我新学校的校长把六年级女生单独关在壁橱里，在我们的胸前乱摸时，我是唯一一个没有告诉妈妈的。因为他是第一浸信会教堂的执事，而我是个妖女。
Julie Showalter's short story first appeared in Other Voices , a literary journal published by the University of Illinois in Chicago. She's the author of the forthcoming novel, Needle Work .
朱莉·肖沃尔特的短篇小说首次发表在伊利诺伊大学芝加哥分校出版的文学期刊《其他声音》上。她是即将出版的小说《针线活》的作者。
Coming up, what really scares people today, really, and your screams. It's in a minute, when our program continues.
接下来，什么才是人们今天真正害怕的，节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a theme, and invite a variety of writers and performers to take a whack at that theme with short stories, monologues, mini documentaries, whatever they can think of. And it is the Halloween edition of our program. And our theme is, things that are supposedly scary, but are not really scary. We are at Act [? Four. ?] And I actually got the idea to play you this next interview, the interview that will make up most of Act Four, when Shawna Kennedy, that Texas woman who dresses up as vampire, said the following thing to me, about her and her colleagues at Haunted Verdun Manor.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家和表演者通过短篇小说、独白、微纪录片或任何他们能想到的形式来探讨这个主题。今天是我们的万圣节特辑。我们的主题是：本该恐怖但实际上并不恐怖的事物。我们来到第四幕。当得克萨斯州那位扮演吸血鬼的肖娜·肯尼迪谈到她和在凡尔登庄园的同事时，我萌生了播放这段采访的想法。
They all take a real joy in doing mean things to perfectly nice people.
他们从对完全友善的人做卑劣的事中得到了真正的快乐。
What's the pleasure in doing mean things to perfectly nice people?
对完全友善的人做卑劣的事有什么乐趣？
You can do it. You have the power to.
你可以做。你有权力这么做。
This picture of power reminded me of interviews I've done with Chicago gang members. And, in a certain way, gang members are perfect for a Halloween program. After all, what are most people really afraid of? Not goblins, not ghosts, most people are scared of armed urban teenagers who just don't care. They just don't care. And I would make the case, I believe that this fear, like the other fears in our program, is not totally justified. But you can judge for yourself. This is an interview with a young woman who was a gang member for years, who now counsels girls in Chicago gangs.
这种权力的画面让我想起了我采访芝加哥帮派成员时的情景。从某种意义上说，帮派成员非常适合万圣节节目。毕竟，大多数人真正害怕的是什么？不是妖精，不是鬼魂，大多数人害怕的是武装的、毫不在乎的都市青少年。他们什么都不在乎。我会提出这样一个观点：我相信这种恐惧，就像我们节目中的其他恐惧一样，并不是完全合理的。但你可以自行判断。这是一次采访，受访者是一名曾多年混迹帮派的年轻女性，现在她在芝加哥的帮派中为女孩提供咨询。
I was 12. I was 74 pounds, maybe four foot in all. My mother thought I was her little angel. My grades were decent, my teachers liked me. I didn't get in very many fights at school. It was when I was out in my other neighborhood, this is where I became this big, bad, super person. And this is where I did all my damage. And why? Because I could.
我当时12岁，体重74磅，身高大概只有4英尺。我妈妈认为我是她的小天使。我的成绩还不错，老师也喜欢我。我在学校没打过几次架。但当我待在另一个街区时，那就是我成为那个大、坏、超级厉害的人的地方。我做了很多破坏。为什么？因为我能这么做。
How did you get rank in the gang?
你是如何在帮派里获得地位的？
Me and a girlfriend went into a school, broke into a school, kind of destroyed some stuff. And we got recognized for it.
我和一个女朋友进了一所学校，闯入学校，破坏了一些东西。我们因此得到了认可。
Did they tell you, here's what you're going to do? Here's your mission?
他们告诉你，这就是你要做的？这就是你的任务吗？
No, there's kind of-- see, what happened was this. There was a teacher who was bothering somebody else. And what we were to do was go and scare this teacher. So what we did was we waited till everybody was gone and everything. And we broke inside the school. Then we went to her room and tore it up. And that was enough.
不，事情是这样的。有一个老师在骚扰别人。我们要做的就是去吓唬这个老师。所以我们等到大家都走了，闯进学校。然后我们进了她的办公室，把里面拆了。这就够了。
Did you put gang signs on the wall so everyone would know who did it?
你们在墙上画了帮派符号，好让大家知道是谁干的吗？
On the chalkboard in--
在黑板上——
In chalk?
用粉笔？
In chalk, because the pen wouldn't write on it. And we didn't have no spray paint. In chalk, and we did do a couple markers on the walls and stuff. And on her desk, we did a nice big one, to let her know like where it came from. Because he threatened her, and we were his threat backup. So she left him alone after that. So I guess it got our point across.
用粉笔，因为笔在上面写不了。而且我们没有喷漆。用粉笔，我们在墙上还用马克笔画了一些记号。在她的桌子上，我们画了一个很大很漂亮的符号，让她知道是谁干的。因为他威胁了她，而我们是他的威胁后盾。所以那之后她就不再骚扰他了。我想这达到了我们的目的。
This poor old lady, she didn't know anything. And she wasn't hassling him because she just wanted to hassle him. She was hassling him because he deserved it. Especially now that I work with children, I see that she was hassling him because he deserved to be hassled, because he wasn't doing what he was supposed to be doing. And yet, we just rocked her world. I mean, she was afraid for-- lord knows-- maybe years after that.
这个可怜的老太太，她什么都不知道。她不是因为想找茬而找茬，她找他麻烦是因为他活该。尤其是现在我从事儿童工作，我发现她骚扰他，是因为他活该被骚扰，因为他没做他该做的事。然而，我们毁了她的世界。我是说，她可能在好几年之后依然感到害怕。
She was?
真的吗？
She was. She was very scared. Because I went to that same school. And she was very afraid. When we went in that Monday, she was very afraid. I mean, we had tore everything up that was hers, everything. And it was cruel, real cruel. I think a lot of things we did were real cruel.
是真的。她非常害怕。因为我也在那所学校。当周一我们进去的时候，她非常害怕。我们毁了所有属于她的东西，全部。那很残忍，真的很残忍。我想我们做的很多事都很残忍。
When we were there, it wasn't like, shh, be quiet. No, it was like, throw everything, scream, laugh about it.
当我们在那里时，可不是“嘘，安静点”。不，是到处扔东西、尖叫、大笑。
See, this is the  thing. I don't know how to even capture it or explain it on the radio. And that is the difference in reality, if you're in the gang, versus the way you see it if you're not in. I mean the way that you all saw what you were doing was, it's kind of fun. You guys laugh about it.
这就是关键所在。我不知道如何在电台上捕捉或解释这一点。这就是现实的差异，如果你在帮派里，和你不在帮派里看到的感觉是不同的。你们所有人都觉得自己在做的事——挺有趣的。你们会对此大笑。
It was a power trip. It's power. When you're 13, and you can walk down the street, and everybody looks at you like, there goes the Pope, that's a power trip.
那是一种权力快感。那是权力。当你13岁，走在街上，每个人都像看教皇一样看着你，那是一种权力快感。
When you're on the street, some people can just walk up to somebody and just smack them, just smack the hell out of them. That would be it. But I was more like, what, you said something about me? You got something to do about that? I would lead it on.
在街上，有些人可以直接走到某人面前，直接扇他们耳光。就是这样。但我更像那种，你是说你对我说了什么？你有什么想说的吗？我会引导它。
I could get my anger up, before I could muster up my courage, talk to them, argue with them, get your momentum up, get your anger. Get that nice wild flush in your face or something, and then like the nice crowd that's behind you saying, kick her ass, hit her, all this. And then you get this bold stance on you, and then you can hit someone. And you get all your nice anger out. But I couldn't just walk up and smack somebody.
在我鼓起勇气说话、争论、蓄势之前，我可以激起我的愤怒。增加我的动力，激发愤怒。让脸上泛起那种狂野的潮红，然后身后那群好帮手说“踹她，打她”，所有这些。然后你就会站稳脚跟，打向别人。你把你所有的愤怒都发泄出来。但我无法直接走过去扇人耳光。
And the girls who you see now?
那你现在看到的那些女孩呢？
The girls who I see now are lost. They're so lost, they're like that all the time. They think they know everything. And they don't need know reason because they know everything. So all they need to do is go up there and do it. And one time my cousin said, well I just went up there and I clocked her. I said, you clocked her? You just clocked her? You didn't even say anything to her? She said, no, I didn't need to say anything to her. All I had to do was walk up and clock her. I said, so you walked up to her, you clocked her in the face, and that was it? She says yeah. And I'm like, what were you thinking, when you walked-- She goes, I wasn't.
我见到的女孩们都迷失了。她们太迷失了，她们一直都是那样。她们以为自己什么都知道，她们不需要理由，因为她们什么都懂。所以她们要做的就是走过去干。有一次我表妹说：“我就走过去，给了她一拳。”我说：“你给她一拳？你就直接给她一拳？你甚至没跟她说话？”她说：“不，我不需要跟她说话。我只要走过去给她一拳就行了。”我说：“所以你走过去，照脸给她一拳，就这样？”她说：“是啊。”我在想，你走过去的时候在想什么？她说：“我什么都没想。”
I don't like some of what I did because when I try to reach out, and I try to tell the kids, you shouldn't do this because it's bad, and you'll hurt people. And they'll say, you did it.
我不喜欢我过去做的一些事，因为当我试着去接触那些孩子，试着告诉她们：“你们不该这样做，因为这不好，会伤害别人。”她们会说：“你以前不也做了吗？”
Yeah, but I would think actually that could work to your advantage. You'd say, yeah I did it. And I'm sorry.
是啊，但我认为实际上那可以转化成你的优势。你会说：“是的，我做过。我很抱歉。”
For some of them it does. For some of them it doesn't, because they can't get past-- because I can say to some of them, yes, I did. And this is how I feel about it now, and I regret it. But some of them, they can't get past the fact that I did do it, so that makes it correct. And every time you turn around they say, but you did it, but you did it. And it's not the fact that I did it, it's the fact that I did it, I regret it, and I got out. That's what I want to pass, that I got out, and I regret it.
对她们中的一些人确实有效。对另一些则不然，因为她们无法跨过那个坎——因为我可以告诉她们中一些人：“是的，我做过。这就是我现在的感受，我感到后悔。”但她们中有些人无法接受我真的做过的事实，因为那样就代表那是正确的。每次你转过身，她们就说：“可你也做了，可你也做了。”关键不在于我做了，而在于我做过，我后悔了，并且我脱身了。我想传递的是：我脱身了，我感到后悔。
See, but what they're saying to you, in a way, is even more interesting. What they're saying to you is, I'm not so bad. I'm not so bad. Look, what I'm doing isn't so bad, because, look, you did it, everybody does it. You're telling me that I'm bad. You're telling me the way I am is wrong. But I know in my heart that I'm not that wrong.
你看，但她们用另一种方式对你说的话更有意思。她们是在对你说：“我不算太坏。我没那么坏。看，我做的事没那么坏，因为看，你也做了，每个人都做。你在告诉我我很坏。你在告诉我我的生活方式是错的。但我内心知道我没那么错。”
See, that's like, when I was doing all this. There was nothing wrong. There was nothing wrong. I mean, so what? So I went in there and I wrecked a classroom. So what? So I hit somebody in the head or the ear, they shouldn't have been messing with me. So what?
你看，那就像，我当时做这一切的时候。没什么错。那没什么错。我是说，那又怎样？所以我闯进去砸了一个教室，那又怎样？所以我打了别人的头或耳朵，他们不该惹我，那又怎样？
Even as you say it, your whole face turns into like a 14-year-old. I mean, you like shake your head, and like you kind of swagger. It's just like your whole personality just transforms.
哪怕你说的时候，你的整张脸都变回了14岁的时候。我是说，你摇着头，还有点那种耀武扬威。就像你的整个人格都转化了。
That's why, in a way, it's hard for me to talk about this, because I do, I change. And I start the, so what, and I don't care.
这就是为什么，从某种程度上，我很难谈论这个，因为我确实变了。我开始“那又怎样”，开始“我不在乎”。
We lived on the corner of Beech and Spalding, right there, where they would kill people and hang them from the light post.
我们住在比奇街和斯伯丁街的拐角处，就在那儿，他们会杀人并将他们吊在灯柱上。
They hung people from light post?
他们把人吊在灯柱上？
They hung one person. And what it was, it was around Halloween. And what they did is they put jogging pants and filled it with newspaper, and they put a hood, and they put a banana hanging out of his [? virtuous ?] place. And they hung him from the lightpole. And nobody knew, because it looked like a dummy hanging there.
他们吊过一个人。那是在万圣节前后。他们把慢跑裤里塞满报纸，戴上头套，还在他的（敏感部位）挂了一根香蕉。他们把他吊在灯柱上。没人知道，因为看起来就像挂在那儿的一个假人。
But it was a human being?
但那是一个活人？
It was a human being.
那是一个人类。
Dead?
死了？
Dead. Not alive anymore. See that was from a whole big war. And that was our victory or whatever with this person. And he had certain colors on, certain color jogging pants, certain color jogging shirt that he had on, certain color gloves, fingers bent down on the glove and all that stuff to represent.
死了。不再活着了。那是由于一场巨大的战争。那是我们对于那个人的胜利之类的。他穿着特定的颜色，特定的慢跑裤、特定的慢跑衫，戴着特定颜色的手套，手指弯曲在手套里，所有这些东西来代表。
In death, they pushed his fingers into his gang sign?
在死的时候，他们强行让他摆出了帮派手势？
No, no, I didn't say his gang sign. They just had the gloves on it, and they had the glove taped down, holding upward our gang sign, not his. Not his-- ours up.
不，不，我没说是他的帮派手势。他们只是把手套戴在上面，然后把手套粘住，向上比出我们的帮派手势，不是他的。不是他的——是我们的手势向上。
Our you one of the people who did that?
你也是做这件事的人之一吗？
No. I was too young.
不，我太小了。
But you saw them do it?
但你看见他们这么做了？
I didn't see them do it. I just knew about it.
我没看见他们做。我只是知道这件事。
People must have laughed about it.
人们一定对此大笑吧。
It was hilarious. I mean, to them. I was too young. I was maybe eight. I remember seeing it. I remember it there. I remember asking my mother why he's there.
太滑稽了。我是说，对他们来说。我太小了，我大概八岁。我记得看到过。我记得它在那里。我记得问妈妈为什么他在那里。
What did she say?
她说什么？
She said that she don't know, and she don't want to know.
她说她不知道，也不想知道。
And what did you think of it at eight?
八岁的时候你是怎么想的？
At age eight, I just kind of wondered why it was there, and how they got it up there. That was my whole big thing. I think that, as a child, you wonder those things. And I just kept wondering, how did they get it up there? And I just thought it was newspaper. And it was a person.
八岁的时候，我只是有点好奇为什么在那儿，以及他们是怎么把它弄上去的。那是我最大的困惑。我想，作为孩子，你会好奇这些。我一直在想，他们是怎么弄上去的？我当时以为那只是报纸做的。而那是一个人。
And how long was it up there?
它挂了多久？
It was up there a couple days. It was up there a couple days. Because it was like stenching, it smelled, and they cut it down. The police came, and they cut it down. And the banana had already fell off. And that was it. And nobody said anything. Nothing went out. There was no screams. There was no nothing. There was just somebody come, cut it down, picked it up, put it in a truck. Police came, scanned the area, came back once. That's it. Nothing was ever mentioned, nothing.
在那儿挂了几天。因为那是腐烂的，有臭味，他们把它割了下来。警察来了，把它割了下来。香蕉已经掉了下来。就这样。没人说什么，没有任何消息传出去。没有任何尖叫，什么都没有。只是有人来，把它割下来，捡起来，扔进卡车。警察来了，扫描了现场，回来了一次。就这样。什么也没提起，什么都没有。
Now we move to Act Six, Screams. Well, a few months ago we introduced you to Dr. Greg Whitehead, of the Institute for Scream Studies, who has been collecting screams from around the world. And his thesis is this. He says that we tend to think of the scream as a kind of monochromatic, sort of binary unit of information. Someone either screams or they don't. They express a kind of scream-ness, or they do not.
现在我们转向第六幕，尖叫。几个月前，我们向您介绍了来自“尖叫研究中心”的格雷格·怀特海德博士，他一直在世界各地收集尖叫声。他的理论是这样的：他说我们倾向于将尖叫视为一种单一的、二进制的信息单位。要么某人尖叫了，要么没尖叫。他们表达了一种“尖叫性”，或者没有。
Whitehead says that is very simplistic. That there are hundreds of different kinds of screams, and there's meaning to divine from screams. And we have to divine that meaning. And he invited your screams, yours, for his collection, for his analysis. And dozens of you called and left your screams on voicemail. And I felt, what would a Halloween program be without screams?
怀特海德说这太简单化了。尖叫有数百种不同的类型，尖叫中蕴含着意义，我们必须去解读那种意义。他邀请你们参与他的收藏和分析，提供你们的尖叫。你们中有几十个人打了电话，在语音信箱里留下了尖叫声。我想，没有尖叫声的万圣节节目还算什么呢？
[BEEP] Please enter your mailbox-- [BEEPS] Your mailbox is almost full.
（哔声）请输入您的信箱……（哔声）您的信箱快满了。
Hi, my name is Oliver, and I'm going to leave my scream. [SCREAM]
嗨，我叫奥利弗，我要留下我的尖叫。（尖叫）
[SCREAM] I never really thought much about screams, but it is rather purging.
（尖叫）我从没认真考虑过尖叫，但这确实相当排毒。
I just got off, and I am completely frustrated with a fellow employee. [SCREAM]
我刚下班，对一位同事感到非常沮丧。（尖叫）
The message will be saved.
信息将被保存。
I live in Scottsdale, Arizona. And I work at a company that works six days a week, 12 hours a day. I'm so sick of it, that I want to scream. [SCREAM]
我住在亚利桑那州的斯科茨代尔。我在一家每周工作六天、每天12小时的公司工作。我厌倦透了，我想尖叫。（尖叫）
[SCREAM]
（尖叫）
Hi, I'm the lead singer in a band called Hatewave in Chicago. And I heard a little bit about your studies, and it reminded me of the music I play in this band. The lyrics are all screaming, and screaming is a really great thing. And it's a lot of fun to listen to. So I'll give you the first verse from a song called "Vodun Goat". [SCREAM]
嗨，我是芝加哥一个叫“仇恨波”乐队的主唱。我听到了一点关于你们的研究，它让我想起了我在乐队里演奏的音乐。歌词全是尖叫，尖叫是一件非常棒的事情，听起来很有意思。所以我给你们唱一首叫《沃登山羊》的歌的第一段。（尖叫）
Sometimes when I'm depressed, I go by myself into a closet and I scream like crazy. [SCREAM]
有时当我抑郁时，我会独自躲进壁橱里疯狂尖叫。（尖叫）
I think screaming is a release, but I don't have that much to release, because I think it's kind of funny, after listening to your message. So I'm just going to scream a little, OK? Here I go. [SCREAM]
我认为尖叫是一种释放，但我没那么多东西需要释放，因为我觉得在听了你们的信息后这挺好笑的。所以我只是尖叫一下，好吗？我来了。（尖叫）
Yes, hi. I think this a very interesting proposition, because I think screams reveal a lot of subtleties of character. And I've always liked sounds, sound for its own sake. So I think this is really interesting. And when I was growing up, I was not allowed to scream. I was a very, very quiet, good child, so for me to scream, at all, in public is really unusual. So here I go. [SCREAM]
是的，嗨。我认为这是一个非常有趣的提议，因为我认为尖叫揭示了许多细腻的性格。我一直喜欢声音，单纯为了声音本身。所以我认为这真的很有意思。当我长大时，我不被允许尖叫。我是一个非常、非常安静的好孩子，所以对我来说，在公共场合尖叫真的很不寻常。所以我来了。（尖叫）
Hi, I'm eight. One thing that makes me scream is-- when I go on a roller coaster, I scream because I'm having fun. [SCREAM]
嗨，我八岁。让我尖叫的一件事是——当我坐过山车时，我尖叫是因为我很开心。（尖叫）
I think I'd feel dumb if I screamed, so I'll just hang up.
我觉得如果我尖叫我会觉得很蠢，所以我挂断了。
OK, [SCREAM]
好的，（尖叫）
Hello, I was listening to the radio the other night, and I heard abou the scream line. And I just thought I'd kind of leave a little story on how I scream, and where I do my screaming. Right now, I'm calling you from a car phone. I work in Sacramento, California, and I live in the San Francisco Bay area.
你好，我那天晚上在听收音机，听说了尖叫热线。我只是想留下一个小故事，讲讲我怎么尖叫，以及我在哪尖叫。现在我正从车上打电话给你们。我在加利福尼亚州萨克拉门托工作，住在旧金山湾区。
And I make a drive of 109 miles, not every day, but at least three times a week, back and forth. And so I'm dealing with customers at my job, and I also have to deal with the other participants in this commute. So what I do is, when I'm in the car, and I reach about, well, it's about this point in the drive-- I guess, I'm about 75 miles into the drive-- I always, get all my anger, and stress, anxieties, and everything else with a good old scream.
我开车要走109英里，不是每天，但至少每周三次。我工作中要应付客户，还得应付通勤路上的其他参与者。所以我这么做，当我在车里，大概到了——嗯，大约是车程的这个点——我想，我已经开了大约75英里了——我总是用一次痛快的尖叫来发泄我所有的愤怒、压力、焦虑以及其他的一切。
I really didn't know anybody else did anything like this until I heard your radio show. So here's my scream, and this is what I do. [SCREAM] And I really do feel much better after I do that. It clears my lungs. I actually can see better. Even though I wear glasses, I actually can see better.
在听到你们的电台节目之前，我真的不知道还有人这么做。所以这是我的尖叫，这就是我所做的。（尖叫）这样做之后我真的感觉好多了。它清理了我的肺部。我甚至看得更清楚了。虽然我戴着眼镜，但我确实看得更清楚了。
[SCREAM] Thank you.
（尖叫）谢谢。
[SCREAM]
（尖叫）
Hello, I was just feeling like screaming, so I figured this was the place to call. And it's hard to think of actually doing it. It would be nice to-- I thought when I was going to call this number that maybe it would be requested to scream or encouraged to scream.
你好，我只是想尖叫，所以我想这是该打过来的地方。但我真的很难想到该怎么做。如果能——我原本想当我打这个号码时，也许会要求我尖叫或鼓励我尖叫。
But it's so hard to do here in the city. And I'm out in a bungalow on the northwest side of Chicago. And the neighbors are probably about four to, I don't know, six feet away, or maybe 12 feet away with some walls in between. And I just feel like it wouldn't be appropriate to scream.
但在城市里太难了。我住在芝加哥西北区的一个平房里。邻居们大概距离四到六英尺，或者有墙隔着大概12英尺远。我只是觉得尖叫不太合适。
So I wish I could be someone who could scream. When I was living in the mountains in California, I could sing my screams, and just do it. It was great. It was a wonderful way to express myself and to release a lot of things that I was holding in. But I can't do it in the city. So that's what I wanted to say. Maybe I'll call back another time and say stuff too. OK, thank you, bye bye.
所以我希望我能成为一个会尖叫的人。当我住在加利福尼亚的山里时，我可以唱歌般地尖叫，随心所欲。那太棒了。这是一种表达自我和释放压力的绝佳方式。但在城市里我做不到。所以这就是我想说的。也许我下次还会打过来再多说点。好的，谢谢，再见。
[SCREAM]
（尖叫）
On the count of three. One, two, three. [SCREAM] There's our power yell from the Los Angeles Commission on Assaults Against Women. [APPLAUSE]
数到三。一，二，三。（尖叫）那是来自“洛杉矶妇女反攻击委员会”的能量呐喊。（掌声）
The message will be--
信息将——
[WHISPERING] I'm in the library right now, so I can't scream very loud. [SCREAM] Thank you, I feel better.
（耳语）我正在图书馆，所以我不能大声尖叫。（尖叫）谢谢，我感觉好多了。
To end the session-- [BEEP] Good bye.
结束本次会话——（哔声）再见。
That radio experiment from Dr. Greg Whitehead in Massachusetts.
那是来自马萨诸塞州格雷格·怀特海德博士的电台实验。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself, with Peter Clowney, Alix Spiegel. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin.
嗯，今天的节目由南希·厄普代克和我本人制作，参与人员还有彼得·克劳尼、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资助方名单）
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, and, and, and, what, what's coming up next?
WBEZ管理监督：托里·马拉蒂亚，还有，还有，还有，接下来是什么？
Stay tuned for Password with Allen Ludden. And he said, his brother screamed at the screen. You bastard! You bastard!
“请继续收看艾伦·勒登的《密码》节目。”他说，他弟弟对着屏幕尖叫道：“你这混蛋！你这混蛋！”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带给您更多《美国生活》的故事。